you just said my name is randy's which I
work at Omni sigh we used to be called
map D up until I think two or three
weeks ago as it turns out there was a
lot of confusion about what our name
meant relative to what our product does
and so rather than have to keep
introducing that we just switched our
name so what does omnis I actually do on
this I is a GPU accelerated relational
database and analytics platform and
what's really great about GPUs is the
massive parallelism works really well
with the type of workloads that are
generally done on relational databases
and so if you're doing something you
know like a group by statement or a
filtering statement and you know where
Clause GPUs actually worked really well
for this use case because of the massive
bandwidth that GPUs can stream data
through as well as the massive
parallelism that you get with GPU core
before I go any further do I actually
need to explain what a GPU is or is
everybody comfortable with that I didn't
want to insult others intelligence to
start off with but I'm happy to go over
it if if anyone would like me to
sure so the way I like to explain the
difference between a CPU and a GPU would
be something like a school bus versus a
Ferrari if you want to get somewhere
really really quickly and especially if
you want to go in a straight line or a
racetrack a Ferrari is fantastic and in
this case in my analogy the Ferrari is a
CPU so CPUs clock speeds go really fast
they're general-purpose in some natures
but ultimately you can do one thing
really fast ok GPU on the other hand is
the school bus in this analogy so GPUs
in terms of clock speed are much much
slower but if you want to get 50 people
you know down the street it turns out
that the GPU or your school bus and this
example is the better way to do it it
may move slower but you move more
through ok so you move more people down
the street and so GPUs for the longest
time were used to render graphics on a
computer but in roughly 2007 or 2008
some enterprising researchers realize
that that graphics your regular image is
really just a two-dimensional
two-dimensional matrix of values they
said well hey you know a lot of science
scientific computing and machine
learning are two-dimensional arrays of
numbers as well and so they realized for
what ended up becoming CUDA the the
acceleration library that you could do
relatively the same thing and so again
what makes GPUs really great for
analytics is that you're going to
essentially do the same operation to
different data elements all at the same
time so if I want to square a million
elements I don't need to do them one at
a time I can do say $5,000 more however
my GPU cores that you have and if you
can't Rast that to a CPU it may be able
to do that operation faster
but you end up doing those operations
serially and it takes longer overall
okay
and so Omni side was built from the
ground up to work with GPUs and so while
I'm nice I'm a not be as flexible a tool
as something like post grass for the
operations that we are optimized for we
are extremely extremely fast and so what
I'm going to do today is present
omni's I just briefly because I don't
want this to be a vendor talk I don't
want this only to be a vendor talk I
want to actually show all the work that
is going on as part of something that's
called the GPU open analytics initiative
of which Omni size part of okay before I
get go too much further I don't want to
forget this we just raised a bunch of
money and we need to hire a lot of
people so if any of you are C++
engineers CUDA engineers specifically
like giving talks and would like to be
on my team
we are hiring lots and lots of people we
are a remote friendly company so that
pitches out there if anything you see
here today interests you please come
talk to me afterwards and of course if
the product just you as well please come
talk to me so what I want to do is
demonstrate an end and workflow where
the data stays on GPUs throughout the
whole time and the data source that I'm
going to be demonstrating is electricity
demand the eastern part of the United
States and so we're Omni size fits in
for a GPU open analytics initiative is
we're a great storage and computation
medium to start off with your data
exploration
so as I said before about our name
confusion just as a tangent almost
everyone a redeemed us has a map of some
sort in it and that's where the
confusion came in so everyone thought we
were only mapping software but as it
turns out the relational database
capabilities are a much stronger piece
of our product offering than the maps
but nevertheless we have a map here that
outlines the region for the electricity
demand that we're going to evaluate and
so I just have a simple dashboard here
showing our data set for electricity
demand over maybe a ten year period
yourself and you know there's plenty of
tools that can display data like this
but we're I'm nice I becomes interesting
is that everything that's on here is
being rendered by GPU instead of having
the data being transferred from the GPU
to locally on the CPU and then render
with JavaScript and why is that
important well for the the data set that
I'm using here which is relatively
modest in size it's not a big deal
but if you want to have drill down
capability of anywhere in the United
States for hundreds of thousands
millions billions of data points you
can't stream that across the browser you
need to either down sample your data or
just not visualize it at all which has
been the sort of current state of
affairs and what GPU rendering allows
for is that you know we can get record
level granularity while also having
interactivity and so this map here again
highlights the the region of interest
that were we're going to talk about but
if we want to start looking at our data
we have this heat map here and we can
use this for cross filtering we can
drill into any portion of our data at
any time and the the easiest way to sort
of see this is by using this crossroads
link tool at the bottom here and so as I
go through this is all going in real
time there's no caching
in fact on the side doesn't support
indexing at all
GPUs from sort of a brute force
perspective can stream the data through
so fast that it actually slows us down
to have indexing and so as you can see
we can just go through this data point
here and we can slide through and all of
this is being sent back all of these
tiles submit a query to the database the
database sends the data back and so we
can start to get a level of
interactivity that you're not going to
get from a lot of other tools and so
from what this data actually means
perspective so as we scroll over this
this chart at the bottom here as you'd
expect electricity demand is very
cyclical anything that has a human
behavior involved tends to be very
cyclical so you know times where people
who are awake obviously people are going
to use a little more electricity than
when they're sleeping when it's hotter
outside air conditioning tends to drive
up electricity usage and then you start
to see with the electricity demand chart
over here an interesting perspective of
you get these dips and so the how people
consume electricity tends to differ
between the summer months in the winter
months and so every time you see this
bimodal chart pattern these tend to be
our winter months and again we can go
over this you know through any any time
period we can scroll around okay so this
is the gist of what the omni site
platform does we provide a reporting
platform that's gpu-accelerated
but we also have a raw database editor
or you can type in sequel and things of
that nature yeah
is the difference CMOS engineering in
digitalization lets us require talking
you're done juicing the theory I'm sorry
could you repeat the question you know
yeah I suppose I give you a different
database with a different schema there's
a lot of different things so that
requires continuing and that is
delegated fuel so that's a you know is
something have customer needs to at the
company or something that they're using
yes pls oh no all of this can be done by
the end-user it doesn't require coming
to us in fact the core on the side
engine is actually open source so you
don't have to ever talk to us if you
don't want to if you want to use this
visualization interface this is part of
our enterprise product but ultimately
also plan on spending too much time on
this but we have like many different
database engines you could just import
your data through our browser if you
have a small of data set we provide
Python JavaScript bindings if you want
to do your work that way
I'm a command-line interface we accept
streams from Kafka any number of tools
and so no you don't have to ever ever
talk to us okay so for this example I'm
using a Microsoft Azure instance this is
just a coincidence doesn't happen to be
that because we're Microsoft our product
works on any of the major cloud
providers it works if you have your own
GPUs in a data center we also have a
product called Omni side cloud which is
the software as a service platform
that's where we actually have the our
own platform where we're hosting GPUs
and deal with all the maintenance but
ultimately anyway you want to run this
you can
in terms of minimum requirements we get
the most speed up if you can have your
data in GPU Ram and so when I'm at home
I use consumer grade GPUs if you're
going to do this in an enterprise
setting you'll want to use data center
quality GPUs if you can scale both
horizontally and vertically and so for
the most parts each GPUs tends to be the
most that you can get into one node
without doing weird things on the side
as I said both horizontal scaling and
vertical scaling so we do support
distributed distributed node GPU
clusters as well okay so this is where
we're going to start with all of our
data can be stored in map D and so now I
want to actually get into the part that
that moves the ball forward so using our
library which is still called PI map D
that will eventually change we're going
to import data from Omni Sai into Python
but what we're going to do here is
through inter process communication
we're not going to transfer the data
anywhere from the GPU what we're going
to do at really low-level terms is on
these side returns a pointer to the data
and then PI map D reads that pointer and
it leaves the data in the same location
and this is where you end up getting a
very interesting workflow is that
through the the power of Apache arrow
we're all it's possible that multiple
different tools can pass references to
to the same data set in the same memory
location never serializing the data and
that's really the the biggest issue not
the biggest but a painful issue in data
science when you have to transfer data
from one system to another and how do
you do that whether you know you're
passing CSV files around or
you know maybe you're using Hadoop and
you have park' files and you're trying
to pass this from here to there and in
the this data serialization in and out
of tools wastes a great majority of time
and so what go AI that the GPU open
analytics initiative along with Apache
Aero is really trying to solve for is by
using a common in memory format you can
avoid all this copying and passing data
around okay so to do this there's some
relatively you know normal is this big
enough to just should I make this bigger
or people see this bigger all right
okay and so this is relatively standard
code I'm gonna be importing pandas pi
map D and when we do our connection we
can see that the data that we had in
Omni sigh is now displayed on the screen
and the Jupiter notebook and so this
table is fairly simple in its
construction we have two time stamps the
difference just being G UTC versus local
the region and then M W stands for
megawatts the the amount of energy
demand okay so we want to pull the data
sample again we'll use PI map D to do so
and I've started doing some basic data
cleaning here it really just depends on
how much performance you really need
where you do this data data cleaning in
this case I'm a very big sequal person
as opposed to when I see a sort of
dichotomy if you generally a pandas
person or you're a sequel person you
generally don't see both so I'm a very
big sequel person of course I work at a
database company that makes sense so I'm
doing some really basic feature
engineering here taking the
characteristics of a time stamp and
moving them into separate columns and so
as we do this okay I've just taken a
small sample of data out of the data out
of the database but again we're not
passing it across CPU or not streaming
it to the browser this is just a
reference into GPU memory okay and so
now we have a very simple like I said a
very simple set of features as it turns
out forecasting electricity is actually
a really simple problem I'm in time
series because people behave so
statically people go to work at 8:00
9:00 in the morning come home at 5:00
o'clock they turn on their air
conditioning they go to sleep
10:11 whenever people go to bed so even
though the features are actually very
simple for this model it fits very well
without needing to use any crazy
predictive modeling techniques and so
now that we have our data inside of a
GPU data frame we're gonna I'm just
going to demonstrate using coop I so
this is the CUDA version of numpy how we
can do just a simple linear regression
and predicts energy demand very very
well and so the first thing that I want
to do is one hot encoding so if your
remember the scikit-learn this actually
has the same semantics and scikit-learn
so getting all this acceleration is
somewhat free if you're already in the
Python data ecosystem free being sort of
a relative term because GPUs are
expensive but if you already possessed
GPUs you don't need a lot of specialized
knowledge to do something like this and
so to build my model I'm going to use
day of week month and then hour of the
day which we saw in the dashboard to be
pretty good in terms of being able to
show a decent separation and how people
consume electricity and so when we do
this okay
again if you've done this in
scikit-learn before it should learn it
should look exactly the same we've
created all of these DIF 1-0 flags for
the different combinations of day hour
and month and just because this can be a
little confusing about where we are I
just want to highlight this again then
I'm using the the pandas data pandas
pretty printing interface to show it
here
but the data is actually on the GPU and
so
[Music]
just wanted to point this out here
because again it if if you're watching
this here I'm sure it's probably pretty
tough when are you transferring memory
or when you're not but ultimately I've
not transferred any date off the GPU at
this point it's all references ok so now
like any other predictive modeling
project I'm just going to split the data
into a training and validation set and
again to really just keep reinforcing
this data still in GPU nothing's changed
yeah we're just creating references okay
and so now we can get to the point where
we start doing something that looks like
numpy and so what I'm doing here is just
splitting my data into the independent
variables and another thing that I want
to predict which energy demand and now
we've gone from the GPU data frame to
GPU arrays like you would see in numpy
except rather than using numpy and doing
a transfer from GPU CPU we leave
everything on the GPU and just qu pi
generates CUDA kernels in the background
okay so now if we want to calculate the
the model parameters we can do this a
dozen different ways generally you
wouldn't see anyone do it this way but
I'm only going to demonstrate it because
it's an interesting application of
interesting intersection of linear
algebra and GPU processing so I'm gonna
solve this directly usually you'd
probably see someone do something like
gradient descent to estimate the model
parameters I'm going to use the normal
equation to actually generate this and
one fell swoop and so you can see we
have it takes 497 microseconds to go
through and do the dot product of our X
matrix invert it go through and estimate
all of our all of our model parameters
and so this is one of those areas where
GPU is really shine
as we're going through and trying to do
matrix multiplication again all of those
cells are going to be independent of one
another which means that can be a highly
parallelized problem and in the case of
the GPUs that I'm using I leave the
total cluster has something like 24,000
CUDA CUDA cores I believe this is what
I'm running on one core so you're still
getting 5,000 threads at a time that's
that's solving this problem and again
linear regression isn't a very difficult
problem computationally especially when
you do something like gradient descent
but again I've taken the worst way to
solve this and it still can be done in
500 microseconds and so now we can go
through and actually try and evaluate
this model and again I'm doing all of
this and sort of the linear algebra way
of multiplying through like you'd see in
numpy but again using coop I you're
getting the GPU acceleration essentially
for free because the API of KU PI does
its best to mimic numpy so if you've
already familiar with one you're
generally gonna be familiar with the
other and so then we can go through and
calculate you know some simple
statistics of root mean square error and
then we can do mean absolute percentage
error - as you can see with just this
simple example we've not transferred the
data off of the GPU with just a simple
handful of features
our average errors 9.2 percent and so if
we want to go through and visualize this
this is an area actually cheating and so
depending on how you look at this I am
gonna transfer the data to CPU to do
visualization this is a small enough
data set where it doesn't matter there's
several different ways you could do this
I didn't want to make this a really
vendor heavy sort of situation to import
the data back and omnis i build a
dashboard so i'm gonna just use the map
plot log functionality and so
this area is the cheating part if you
notice here the PD data frame so I've
now transferred the data off the GPU to
the CPU and now we can go through and
visualize our model and so you can see
with just this simple set of features
and really elementary linear algebra
techniques you get a pretty good fit
okay you'll see that for the most part
this data set here let me zoom this make
a little easier to see for the most part
our model does fit human behavior here
with just a handful of dummy variables
and so in the areas where the model
doesn't fit sort of gets into the more
domain knowledge situation where
certainly weather affects how people use
electricity I don't have weather as part
of this data set but if I were to add
that you would see that there's the the
Delta shrink dramatically another area
would be economic activity so depending
on the the area that you're looking in
if it's a booming area electricity usage
goes up because there's more factories
more Commerce if you have a an area
that's not doing so well you should see
electricity demand go down but again
almost all of this other than the
visualization here has been done on the
GPU with no data transfer no no need to
serialize data and so what's sort of the
future of this this is a stylized
example of course it's a small enough
data set that I really could have done
this locally in a CPU but the point of
this is is that great strides have been
made towards solving one of the worst
problems
in my opinion in data engineering and
data science which is again a serial
serializing of data between one place
and another there's something if I click
on here just to get the logo list
there's some something like a dozen
companies that have bought into the GPU
open analytics initiative at this point
anaconda is one of the big sponsors
through the the number CUDA compiler
where I guess the jist GPU in general it
does both MD
there's graph analytics h2o is a machine
learning platform and then through if
you're a a GPU person you've been
following along Nvidia just announced
last week I believe that they've sort of
rebranded the GPU open dialects
initiative into something called Rapids
which is essentially the tools that
makes all this work so all the low-level
C libraries various things and so the
future of this is we hope more tools
will start to buy into this shared
memory platform I know or at least at
one point I think pandas was being
rewritten to use the same memory format
Nvidia claims would be visualization
libraries coming soon so I won't have to
do the cheat that I just did of coming
to matplotlib I'm nice I already does
render the graphics on the GPU but it's
pretty low-level if you know if you're
familiar with Vega the d3 grammar or
Altair so Altair is what Altair is
written in Vega blight which is a
grammar of Vega and vague as a grammar
of d3 so this is all coming close to
fruition there are a couple of rough
edges where one one object doesn't quite
talk to another these are all really
low-level things they're not they're not
going to be solved by the average end
user but ultimately there are a lot of
really talented people working on this
not only at our company
but again Nvidia and all of our partner
companies and so the future I think
of being able to use GPUs for analytics
and and is really bright if you're
interested in how to get started with
this these are all intended to be open
source initiatives and so all of the
code is hosted on github
not just for from the Omni side
perspective but the GPU data frame and
all the surrounding libraries are also
open source open it up to questions
so generally so I'm going to put the
caveat out there that I'm not one of the
engineers that's working on this but
within the various tools you generally
see when the handoff occurs they take
possession of the pointer and so you're
not copying the memory around using the
same reference but eventually one of the
tools takes possession of it to be that
that's more specific unfortunately I can
answer but yeah the idea here is
generally that one process is going to
hand it off to another and then take
possession of that memory location so
python and silver group you know say
arrow memory
as far and then spark company that
matter
I don't know how spark I don't know the
spark internals but yeah so if you look
in our library we use omnis I use this
thrift to pass our messages and so one
of our messages is actually to free the
memory from omni side and so how each of
these tools sort of works through this
will be seen you know i don't know the
internals of all of that but yeah
essentially you're passing the reference
you're not making a copy yeah so I'm
wondering from a database perspective do
you see an issue with having what you
should something that there
you database yes and so the one thing to
keep in mind this is really stuff
specifically for for omnis i is that we
tend to view ourselves as the analytics
platform rather than a transactional
database and so yes if one user is doing
all of their work on the GPU and then
you could have an out of memory
situation but the expectation would be
that an analytics team would sort of
manage out themselves because again this
isn't really for transactions or a
production system where data is going to
be streaming and it has to be readily
available it's more of a exploration
tool so one thing that we do
specifically is we save our data in our
own it's funny it's funny to say this is
I'm talking about
interoperability but we save our data in
our own proprietary binary format
locally and so we use not only GPU Ram
but CPU Ram as a cache and so as people
are using data and sort of the hot state
we try and keep it in the GPU Ram if
data if the other data request comes in
that table
may or may not depending on how much
memory is being used kick out the
original data and push it to CPU Ram and
then if nobody's using and it just gets
we just go back to disk so we're always
storing the data on disk but the thing
about GPUs is the the
with is so high that us streaming the
data from disk tends to be pretty quick
as it is if you're using nvme drives and
then multiple GPUs in parallel you can
get 610 terabyte a second bandwidth and
so it really depends on how large is
large I used to work at a very large
media company and you need lots and lots
of GPUs you'd have to do a distributed
cluster but for many many applications
you really should be ok streaming
streaming the data set across even this
data set here okay this one's 40 42
million data points rendered on a map
right and you're getting full
interactivity with this data set you can
zoom in to wherever you want to go so
this is all being loaded into Ram
we have demonstrations on our website of
a billion or even ten billion data
points where you can get full
interactivity
so we don't only because invidious is
such a dominant player that it really
doesn't even come up from any of our
perspective customers or current
customers
yeah it looks like there's five more
minutes
sure
so we natively support points lines
multi-line polygons Multi polygons we
support just a handful of projections
geospatial is one of our newest
functionalities if this is something
that interests here I'd actually love to
talk to you afterwards about this we're
really trying to understand the needs of
the community if you look at a tool like
post juice there's something like a
thousand operators we're never going to
implement all thousand of them but we'd
love to get you know 85 90 percent of
the normal use cases
okay well there's no other questions you
know thank you all for coming today if
you're interested nama saya ghin as a
product come up and talk to me if you're
interested in especially if you're an
engineer come talk to me if you want a
sticker or a t-shirt I have them
otherwise again thank you all for coming
it was great to be here
[Applause]